subscribers my people as of July 18 2010
which is probably yesterday by now I had
a busy weekend it's the official
one-year anniversary of the day I first
set up my camera and started doing
videos on YouTube time flies yes just
one year ago I was a man who just hated
transformers too and has zero
subscribers oh now I guess I'm just a
man who still hates transformers too but
has 10000 subscribers which is really
awesome I mean I like the concept that
an average guy like me can just set up a
camera do videos on YouTube and it gets
well-received and grows I mean this
badass it's kind of funny how it works
actually after I hit a thousand
subscribers last December my goal was to
hit 10,000 subscribers by my one year
and I just hit 10,000 subscribers
yesterday I made it by one day cutting
it close but I won't lie that was badass
like it was meant to be and I met some
really awesome people on YouTube I mean
I really won't be able to name all you
by name honestly I mean all 10,000 of
you rules so I do apologize for that
most no I've done some collaborative
videos with them theory the film fan
I've done a couple podcast with that guy
always fun I did a podcast with Tom
Channel bash also and Tom Channel bash
interviewed me all of them awesome
people all of them really active
youtubers uploading videos like I do I
mean that blaze kin master guy did
like two videos about me he just did him
I appreciate that man you didn't have to
do that but you did I thank you again
just to name a few I mean like I said
all you guys are badass
so what have I learned in this past year
well one and I think this is a lesson
for everybody if you want to do
something creative just go out there and
just do it just get up don't make
excuses put forth the effort and just do
it it'll be well worth it I promise to
when I see or hear something that I just
hate making a video about it and putting
it up on YouTube for you guys as
entertainment just takes all the
right out of it just makes it
way more bearable things like getting a
ticket and three people really hate it
when you say the real footage and the
fourth kind is actually fake which it is
just saying I still get for that so
all in all I think all 10,000 plus of
you for making this past year a total
game changer for me I mean honestly my
world is literally different now in that
cool good way I cannot thank you guys
enough for making my particular brand of
entertainment well-received I mean it's
just invaluable and I promise all of you
I will continue to make videos until the
internet just explodes or the apocalypse
happens in which case I'll then write
out what I would have filmed and send
them off on the legs of 10,000 plus
pigeons always a plan B so to
commemorate my one-year I put a link
below to the Transformers to review my
video that started it all fair warning
is on my old channel man movie man one
nine one channels I was still kind of
figuring things out so
things were a little rough around the
edges I don't actually post any videos
up on that channel anymore it's just
kind of a dead Channel nostalgia at this
point and also in commemoration of my
one-year I'm going to post a couple of
the fake PSAs that I had on my old
channel I'm gonna post them on this one
why cuz I thought they were funny so
again thank you all for being just
badass and says my goals always multiply
ten times when I had 1,000 subscribers
my goal was 10,000 subscribers on to a
hundred thousand subscribers and here we
go
[Music]